je reconnais que google n'est pas un
lieu de travail conventionnel
ceci étant dit nous avons un règlement
je vais vous poser une série de
questions vous devrez la raquette verte
pour répondre oui et la raquette rouge
pour répondre non bien commençons boire
une bière avec son patron certains
d'entre vous en moins de 21 ans
mais d'autres ont plus de 21 ans alors
si vous voulez vous acheter une avec moi
je serais ravi de voir avec vous je
n'irai sûrement pas rejeter une avec
vous un pétard n'ont pas de pétards je
juge pas je demandais ceci étant dit si
jamais tu veux un truc sympa je fournis
merci arrêté me parler de chacun où il
ya maldonne
je sais pas je comprends pas cette
référence d'accor drogué un collègue
stagiaires et si c'est google barre
mythique points caen et une titulaire
pub accepte ou non plus on dira non à la
bourre en dira non à l'amour exacte non
un coup d'un soir c'est aussi draguer